THE DAYS.G ABOUT G
TAK
ITT EXPLMPHAIN EAR  KNOW ABOULAG
UP TO THOSE CRUC WHERE L KINDUA.
TH WIL, HE
P OK DAYAND THEN OLSON MIAWHAT
HAENTHE PHONE CALL
HE LAWYERSONALD TICE
DEPART, FI
RVG HIM ANSO
TH BE DONE, EE
AN SE L
THTIAL
FAKE>> WE KNOWHE
TO PUT IN EY GENERAL
AND IT THAT WAY. MARK, ATA
BRLE"THANK YOUOUSERVITUDE".
A MUST RIN, I HAVEN' T THING
YET BUT IT'S ONE YOU PUT FIRST A
ENT TR
AT ST E THOF OF THE  EXPLOVEINF
UNDERMINOFTIIT
CASSIDHUTCHINSON, NO ONE
DENIHE
HEPO IS THATONULD HAVE BEEN STOP
OMERS OF RR CH
OR LINDSEY
OR WHOER,JUST
THWE'RSEEINGERE.I DOS
RV HE T DN'T APPARATUSD
HINOOUGH, THIS  ATRUCTIVET FOR O
ANDE SEEM BE WILLING TOEL
ANYTHING ATHATYOVEN A  BEEN IN S
LOIM THIS WAW WEEK EN  S KNORE
>> HAVAR
NO HAPPEN IN A
>> OF CO
THIS COUPLE OF WY
UM.TAHEY'VE
ATY
THIOT ROE V. WADE OVERTURD,
AN EXPANSIVE NEWENDMENT. W IY RT
SENDING HIWA TEYISAN PAR, P AT R
THE REPUBLICAN SOROFD  HE'LLOBAT
D I THINMO
HE'S A PROBLEM FOR DOCBLAN
E'S NOSTUL COULD HAV STOPPED AN
BL UP TO W
YOU WOULJAh,
McCARTAYHE'SEPOK, ER SUPERUMP SE
ISLO
HIM.TH THE
TRONM  EUNS WAD ED
HE HEE KNOW, HE , ME
THE AIGNM IS SEEING WEAKNESS IOI
WHAT'M -INWHAT I WUNTI
AND THAT SORT OFD  STON HI
ON HIS WA AN PARTY EVER SINCE.
FASCINATING ABOUT YOU
PORTIONYESTINGE'
THN
A  FREEDOMYOU M ASUMP'S RSU SAYD
THSHEDOICED HEAD AND
G REFERENCE FOR THE YOU , F  IN
, HE
STOOD BY
WAYS.
T NETO DISF LIT WAY DONALD T INA
ULY THAT -OK, DID THINDOT HAT.
N'
MIKE P OBABLY H NOTT ALL OFNOTYS
P
HE'SUS I REE GOESF HE WANTS JI N
TWO TH BT ONCE
I  D DO TH IT WAS IMPORTANTT.
BACK TO  WOUT BLANY THEY.
D ON THE TVE
ON WE IS OFF O  O
ASANINK THAT'S BEE
ASS